so
hey
hello hi
so hi my name is daniel
as i just said
i'm self-engineering
and i want to talk a little bit about
how we tackle employees how we keep them
fast and how we scale them out while
we're scaling our team
and
quick show hands who knows about etsy
in case you don't know um etsy is the
marketplace where people around the
world connect to buy and sell unique
goods and
just to give you like a rough ballpark
number of where we had
as for august this year we had 1.8
billion page views we had over 5 million
items solved
we had
over 100 million
dollars of goods sold the site has over
30 million members and over 1 million
active shops and you can see that
they're those are kind of typical items
you can buy often so handmade backpacks
earrings notebooks and of course who
doesn't love mustang speakers so
that's the kind of stuff you see when
you go to ksc.com
um
talking about our technology stack we're
a very traditional lamp stack so we run
the linux santos e specific we run
apache man cache mysql and php
behind the scenes
we also have different technology we
have java for the search stack
we still have a postgres database from
which we're trying to focus from which
we're actively migrating off of onto my
simple shards
which are master master replicated
and we also have some python
for infrastructure projects we have
ruby for obvious superchat for
automation our deployment tools written
in ruby
and
a lot of like smaller infrastructure
projects but the main site
the main fc.com when you see when you
browse there is one one of the php app
which we deploy
as one app so
this includes
ads.com the pgc and also our internal
management application for
our support team to manage
emails coming in and all of that
this all is deployed as one
and there are no branches we use gifts
but everybody contributes to master
branch all the time there is no long
living branching going out
because we believe in having continuous
integration on the master branch
and
the use of future plans so what we call
branching and code is actually just
using feature flags inside of your code
to have dark launches and flag features
off until you're
ready to release them
and we do deploy quite a lot
so as you can see here the graph over
the 2013
started out around like
30 40 plus a day and at the end we
were able to scale it up a bit and today
i'm going to talk about how we tackle
that and how we achieved to keep that
fast
those
40 deploys a day are
from roughly 150 com committers so
everybody
of those 150 committers basically
deploys every day
and
how do we like maintain that so one very
important principle we have is on your
first date you deploy
there's nothing more important you could
do there is no paperwork on your first
day there's no
other thing you sit down you write code
and you deploy to seo.com and you get
all the like scary feeling of just
having deployed a huge site and
everything's new but you're excited
right just start your job you want to
change things you want to
improve everything so this is your
chance to be a chance because from the
first day you get to deploy
and usually your first project is just
getting your picture taken in that
phone move right there and then
uploading it to the site because that's
a very small change because we also
believe in very small changes deployed
frequently and it's a very nice
first change because after that you
actually see your picture up on the site
and
that's awesome so how does that work
when you start you log on to ios the
whole company is an irc we have
channels for the operations team we have
channels for infrastructure the core
platform teams there are channels about
ideas channels about tabs channels about
our luncheon learns
and just get acquainted to like talking
to people you place your favorite cat
gift into the channel and
just
talk to people find out what you have to
do and how stack works
for cloud management we use github
enterprise which has
the big advantage that
nowadays everybody has kind of already
used github.com so it's a familiar
interface you already know how to like
browse code do you
know how git works and even if not it's
a very familiar and very friendly
interface to get used to coding get used
to how it works
and also
every developer when they start they get
their own vm and this is a kvn based
santos vm which has the full fc.com
stack shaft onto it it runs the same
chef quickbooks as a production stack
so when you of course in like slim down
version you don't get
70 web servers for your 10 vm but in the
sundown version everything that
runs and powers asi.com runs on your vm
and
we also have one shared repository it's
called devtools where everybody
can just commit scripts to and it gets
synced to all vms so if you have just
discovered a new way of accessing
error logs the database or what gives it
you can just commit it to the repo and
this very much helps us to have this
communal spirit of i just wrote the
script and it helps me so much i
committed to the ricoh just pull and
you'll have it too
and there's also a really nice interface
for creating evms so if you need to test
something if you're working on the
search team
for two weeks which is bigger vms or
something like that you can just go to
our internal web page and create a vm
for you
the general normal vm has five clicks of
ram one cpu and for the use of yes so
if you
run some if you write some code for the
search stack and you need a bigger vm
like say with techniques of ram you go
to the side view
say when vm should be called
you choose to slice cartman because
that's our bigger vm
and you just click the mark for search
and hit the button and you get ready to
go search vm
this
really helps
keeping like keeping development and
production close to each other really
helps for making sure what you write in
development is actually also how it's
going to run production
so
you've been writing code on ibm
you're kind of happy you wrote maybe
your first php maybe you're
already know it
and you want to know even though it's
just an html link and you're first
getting a picture of the page
you want to know if you broke something
if that looks right if that is
how the sfc code should look like
because really from the very first day
you have access to the fce web repo from
your very first day there is nobody
who you have to ask to get the
commitment for the absolutely code
so when you're done writing when you're
done writing a code you can invoke an
internal tool we have which which is
just called review which is a very thin
wrapper around github pull requests to
send a review to
probably the engineer that shows you
around on your first day
or if you've worked it longer to your
peer group of developers who work with
you on a project
and
it will just
open a pull request on the repo
and automatically assign it to the
person you told it to
so
this gives us
a very simple way of taking up reviews
even if you don't know yet because the
local changes you did will be created in
a temporary branch and pushed up to
github and then the local branch will be
deleted so they're from your development
perspective it can just look like
um nothing really happened locally so
it's a very easy way if you don't feel
super familiar with yet to kick up a
review kick of a pull request and get
instant feedback on your code
and since
since it automatically assigns report
requests to the person
uh you can told it to it also
is a nice way to see your github
notifications if someone assigned a
progress to you if you're supposed to
read your code
and as you can see in the picture we
also use that for shaft reviews for
example so
we don't only have operations engineers
working on our chef cookbooks but also
software engineers so if you change
something because you think
the gear man cluster should be set up
differently you can just write chef code
and send a review to
an awesome person for example and they
will use the same workflow to tell you
what to do differently
and
what you can do better when you're just
starting out chat for example
so
reviews are all
awesome but you also want to know if you
bring if you broke the build right and
you want to try out your changes and see
if it breaks something and
as you maybe know a very
famous popular person once said do or do
not there is no try
but as it turns out
we actually have a triangle
where you can just
push
the div you just wrote up to our jenkins
cluster and run your changes on the
jenkins cluster
for that we also have a command line
utility called tri
which just takes that just literally in
http posted to jenkins
and that way you don't have to
run like i o intensive tests on your vm
which is maybe not that fast but you get
the full capacity of our ci cluster um
at your hands so whenever you feel like
this should run full test there's still
a way to
run
signal tests or smaller suits on your vm
but if you want to run the full suit
there is an
excellent way for you to find out if you
broke anything in the yes test suit
so how does tri work well behind the
scenes we have something called the boss
because they
built our tests
and
they're just
basically lxd containers attached to
jenkins we used to have a system uh some
maybe two years ago where we had just
five um big boxes which ran
a number of jenkins slaves which was
kind of awesome because they were named
after transformers so you could like
you know run your tests on bumblebee and
get that nice feeling off hey that's
kind of cool but the problem was that
turns out jenkins executives are really
good when you run one per box but
they're not really good when you run
multiple per single box so they would
trip over each other it wasn't fast
and we also had the problem that for io
intensive
tests it would totally pack the disk
and jobs would influence each other and
it just wasn't optimal so we switched to
an lxc based system but we still have
our big boxes
and we put i think we have four ssds in
there
and
just um split bob's onto ssds so we run
14 ops on one build test and only every
one io intensive job which is labeled in
jenkins
can actually run on a disk
so this way we make sure that no
two jobs which are io intensive run on
the same disk and take each other down
and
yeah so
all in all
our ci and tri cluster has around 260
bops most of them are actually attached
to the tri cluster so we use way more
bobs to actually test developers changes
than we do for the ci
builds we trigger on deploys
and
he constantly also wander slow tests so
we have graphs and alerts and tests that
are slow to figure out when someone
changes a test and suddenly the
characteristics of how the testosterone
changes and slows down it builds because
we have slas around those so we don't
ever want to build
the qa tester for example
when it's
longer than five minutes work so when it
takes longer than five minutes we take a
look at the tests see why and how we can
speed it up because we want it to be
fast and we want to enable developers to
deploy as often as they need to
okay so
now you tested all your changes
and you're going to try you've got the
code review all looks good your picture
looks awesome on the page you checked it
on your vm so it's time to deploy which
at fc means it's time to join the push
string
this is literally what we call it when
we deploy
the train of people which have changes
which need to go out now
and
this is all coordinated on rxc we have a
channel called push
where you just
usually you're in that channel like
every day but you're supposed to join
when you want to deploy
and the schedule of
who
gets to deploy and whose changes go out
is organized in the topic
so
um that means
the topic is the ultimate
like
uh the canonical push frame
schedule and our push view is open from
7 am to 10 pm new york city time which
just means that it's a time where most
of the operations engineer around we
have operations engineers in the uk but
most of them are in the us so it makes
more sense to not have people push code
while there are not a lot of people
around because between 7am 10pm you can
literally push as often as you want so
there is no need to accidentally wake
someone up at night because you felt
like you had to get it out now
and it's just
the more safer way and a nicer way to
deploy
and the push topic looks a little bit
like that so in that case
kyle and james are actually already at
the production stage the first name in
the push train is the so-called driver
which pushes the button to deploy and
everybody else then has just changes in
there and then
the
pipe you know it's the next push train
as you can see in there we also have
config changes in the same trade
so
usually
it looks a little bit more like this
and as you can probably see
hand editing the irc topping in that
case can be really problematic because
you get all those nasty race conditions
where two people try to join and they
override each other's
topic and then you have to remember what
it actually was you have to use the
scroll back so that's why we have an
irish bot called pushbot
and when you go into the channel and
just run dot join it automatically adds
you to the topic so
in 99
of all cases no one hand edits the topic
we all do that through pushbot
and it has commands to
let you tell the group your push frame
that your chains are in so as soon as
you run git push you run dot in to tell
everybody that your chains are in when
you test it on staging and production
you run.good which adds a little
asterisk to your name
so everybody knows that you have tested
your changes
and when the push line is done you just
write done and the next one is up
so
in the ic rc primarily looks a little
bit like this so pushball also
lets you know stuff like
you're on production right now so this
is the link to all the important graphs
you should be watching right now
or when you're outside push hours like
you try to join the push right after 10
pm pushpa tells you
that it's after push hours and
there's a link to an internal wiki page
of
because
it's not
impossible to deploy after 10 pm because
there are emergencies where you have to
flag stuff off where you have to deploy
cash but you have to be aware of
what it entails to deploy after 10 pm so
it leaves a weekly page to just let you
know
so
how does it actually look for the driver
of the push train
how do we actually deploy the code and
for that we have we like to call it one
button deploy but it's actually two
button deploy because we have staging
and then production
and this is the web front end it's the
senator
of how we avoid code so once everybody
has pushed and run the dot in command in
irc
you hit the first button which was
labeled save the princess with tests
that everybody loves and writes tests
and that is also the moment where we
kick off our ci build so at that moment
it deploys the app to staging because
the asset before that goes to templates
and also kicks off the ci build
for
the driver
it looks a little bit like this so
behind the scenes deployment or deploy
tool is basically a huge set of
dispute child commands in rsync and
everything those commands output you get
to see in the run log and
the nice thing about that is that
there's a really great tool in unix to
actually denote arrows which is the
standard error descriptor and
that will show in red on your deploy
screen when something goes wrong so
whenever a command prints something
standard out
you get the error in your web front and
you can immediately check what's going
on
have you broken the build is it because
some server is down
but it also
gives you
an easy way to show notifications so for
example if you're the very first person
to push in the morning someone
get
pushed
the night before but forgot to deploy it
you actually see if there are stale
commits which are by our definition
commits that were pushed six hours or
longer to go
and we'll let you know that there are
changes in your push you might not
expect so you know what to expect when
you push
and
it also checks if all the web servers
are actually available and you can get
the currently deployed version from them
because in your buttons it shows you a
link to the diff that goes out and if
you can't determine the version that's
actually on the webs that's kind of bad
so when that happens it grays off the
buttons and tells you well i do not
really know which version runs in
production so
are you serious about pushing now is
there a problem going on and you can
click to override that
and the pointer will let you know okay
you've chosen to override the version
check that means jenkins stiff urls
might be wrong github if urls might be
wrong
and
more stuff might be broken where we rely
on versions but you've chosen
that deploy to be an emergency deploy so
continue
and there's also a way to lock down all
pushes so
there's something wrong with the github
and you just notice that the totally
push is not
fine
and you don't want it to get up uh to
get deployed
you just hit that button and the web
pushes it all up down and only
you can
clear the lock if you say okay you can
release the hold everything's fine now
clear lock push again
and also the whole system is on github
so if you're interested in setting up
the port items you can go to the url and
check out deployment as i said it's a
simple sinatra app it mostly runs sales
groups in the background
yeah so check it out
we also had a couple of downsides to how
we
managed deploys
one of them was definitely that deploys
running atomic we did our things of all
the code to the webs
to our web servers and then did a
localized thing to actually
take it over into the document route
which meant
at any given point during a deploy you
could simultaneously run a new and old
code in the same document root
so this means there's this like even
though our deploys usually take about a
minute
there's this one minute of time we could
actually be in that limbo state and so a
common strategy was to just split up
your employ your changes into three
deploys which was the first deploy to
add the new functionality the second
deploy to remove the call side of the
old code and then the third deploy to
actually remove the old code because if
you didn't do that you would see
exceptions and missing data and
generally dragons so that was kind of
like a bad state
that's why we decided to implement
atomic deploys
and
how we did that is
from the basic principle
kind of easy so we have two documents
for blues which we call it in yang
and the active uh in document group that
was configured in apache was just
assuming to either one of those
so whenever we deploy we just are saying
to the standby document root
and once that is completely done we
atomically switch the link over
to the new document group
this is a really simple and
nice way of actually doing atomic device
however there are some problems which
you have to know about if you want to
do atomic deployment like that
so the biggest is basically when you do
simulink swapping in between requests
you could get the same problem but you
when you have code that actually
includes
other code we should probably have
because it's not single file yeah
webination you could start a request on
one document booth and finish up on it
on another one and it will have the same
problems as i described before because
we have two different versions of code
so that's why we wrote a small apache
module
which just
does
a real path on the simulink and stores
that as its internal document groups so
it's implemented as a post request code
which means
after apache has actually wrapped the
request from the client it runs
the real path
on the assembly and stores that as its
internal document route and from that
point on the whole request
only knows this document root which is
not which is
in our case uh var dot html generally
yank
and this is the true document route
and we also implemented caching in there
because if you get a lot of requests and
you probably don't deploy faster then
you get requests there is no need of
actually checking if you're still in the
same document room
uh for every request so
our setting is to catch it for two
seconds but it's configurable
as long as you want basically
if you have that in place
you can do if something deploys with
each
simple web basically so
um assets are gonna be
um and their simple php pages are gonna
be in there and
all you have to do on the php side of
things is if you have a similar a single
front controller just set the include
path based on the document group the
patcher gives you
and you're done you have atomic deploy
unfortunately
i absolutely don't have a single front
controller we use
hdx's routing a lot we have different
entry points into the code base so we
couldn't step the include path
at this single front control that's why
we wrote a php module which is kind of
analogously to how the apache module
works
and it just either asks apache for the
document roof
or if you run cli apps for example with
php it does the real path itself
and
stores that as the known server root and
then based on the pattern you give it
which is your configured include path in
your configuration it just replaces
the pattern with the current document
so
that means we can now
remove functions and their call side in
the same deploy we don't have to do any
restarts
because
our opcode cache we'll just pick up the
new files we're using
our cache for that
the event optimizer output cache and
because it's real path based it's going
to cache all the files that have it that
hasn't been changed in between two
deploys so once you do your second
deploy and you're back on your original
document you can still use all the
entries in the cache that haven't
changed since three plus ago which means
there's no heavy cash clearing you don't
have a lot of problems with
cash warming which you would have if you
restart apache for example
but there are also a couple of things to
watch out for
so
your code has to be written to respect
the input path
there can't be any
fully qualified path name inclusion in
your code because then you will not
get the code your current environment is
running on basically
another uh big thing is that atomic
simulink swapping
can only be done if you actually create
a temporary symlink and
mv-t that simply because if you do like
a regular
way of running alarm dash sfn or
whatever it is it actually if you ask
trace it it shows you that it's not
atomic it's creating a temporary link
and then swaps that back in so
you have to use that to actually have it
on deployed
um you want to know your system to
figure out what setting you want to
set for the caching of the actual real
path
and
you have to know that if you run every
two versions like always put a swap
between two versions of the document
group you have to have enough space in
your op cap to actually store two
versions
of your application
and the
atomic system of that system is only
during a request so
while you're deploying for your whole
cluster and you have ajax calls in there
it's possible to have the page render
run on the first um
document rules let's say yin and then it
creates an ajax request which then goes
to another web server and runs on
on gang for example so
it's only atomic in the request
during your request
so this got us a lot of speed up because
you didn't have to split up your
employees anymore into three different
deploys but still we saw kind of a
plateau of
how often we could deploy per day
and how often people were able to deploy
and that was basically because employees
took us about 15 minutes and conflict
employees were a little bit faster but
still there's testing involved you want
to make sure you didn't break staging
you want to make sure you didn't break
production so with the boys
taking about 15 minutes and the normal
working day let's be honest
not a lot of people get up at 7 am to
deploy and not everybody stays until 10
pm their voice so
if we
set like a normal work day where people
may be deployed from 10 am to 6 pm
we only get around like 30 maybe 35 or
40 deploys before there's just not
enough time to actually deploy
and
this resulted in long waiting times so
people were like
i have to wait 45 minutes to get my code
out that's horrible what am i doing
english like twitter and we didn't want
to end up in that situation right
where deploying is the new compiling and
people are like why are you checking
twitter while you're doing handstand and
playing
table tennis and then they'll cancel
so we didn't want to have that deploying
should be
should get out of your way you should be
able to deploy when your code is done so
you can get back to coding and do
what's fun so we basically just split up
the queues so
we now have a push still the push train
which is just for web code and we
created a new
um push channel which is called config
which has the same setup push bar it has
the same rules but it only pushes out
our production php configuration file
so now what we can see
is that it didn't speed up a lot the web
supplies but conflict deploys are now
basically instant and the
cure is always clear because
um
you're not bound to wait for the longer
lasting reptiles to get your quick
conflict changing out
and
that helped a lot with like speeding up
deploys and
making sure as soon as your code is done
you actually um
you can actually deploy it
so
that was mostly about our deployment
system so
now your code is on production right you
have deployed you're fairly sure it
works but can you be really sure and for
that we have an abundance of dashboards
which actually show all employees as
vertical lines
so you actually know
like if you see a spike in the dashboard
is that related to a deploy that that
started earlier did that
like
uh is an impact from an early deploy
from shaft deploy all the changes in our
chef cookbooks also get the ploy line in
there
and most of the important metrics are on
our so-called deploy dashboard so we
have
error pages
check logins checkout for example we
have what we call three on sweater
reports which is just apache throwing
500 for example the current see the end
balance is on there so we're using
multiple cdns and so that you know
which cnn has actually taken most of the
traffic right now and also three metrics
so you know if you just deploy a query
which
is not really nice in the database and
it's now causing pain on the data back
end
we also have what we call supergraph
which is basically
a node.jspace frontend to
tail-f pipe brand
and just shows you all the error logs
from all the webs from the api from
argument workers and like a streaming
web front so after you deployed you just
go to supergraph
and check if there are any like
exception throwings or arrows coming in
and stuff like that
and we also have an internal dashboard
which just
shows you the status of all our internal
tools so whenever we have a problem with
ci we can flag the service ci as having
a problem you can do that from irc you
can go to the web page and flag it but
that actually helps us a lot when
there's a problem so we don't have
everybody coming to the
ci channel asking is there a problem
with ci because you can see it on the
status board and the same goes for
graphite or definitions there's
something of deploymator supergrad and a
lot of other services used daily to help
deploy
so
to summarize a little bit our current
setup has scaled to
around like 150 engineers deploying
every day
and we're constantly trying to improve
the speed of deployment the ease of
deployment and to make it as seamless as
possible in the day-to-day development
workflow that means for us finding
weak parts in the deployment system
listening to developers what really
pains them the most about deploying
and
figuring out ways to make it more robust
make it faster
and also
we're constantly trying to bring
development closer to production because
the only way to know that your changes
are most likely optimal break production
and to be
really sure about that is having
development where you write your code be
as close to production as possible
that's why we run the same chef
quickbooks on development in production
and have the same stack traveling with
the amp directly going to run your code
on in production
and
the last very important point is that
not being able to deploy for us is a
priority one but it has the same
severity as the site heading down
because
we regard being able to deploy
constantly
as
one of or even the biggest one of the
biggest features we can have
for developing the site so
when there's a problem with deployment
everybody who knows how to fix it drops
what they're working on because this is
a priority one but
if you want to know more about it we
have a blog at codesgraphs.com
there are a lot more talks uh that go
deeper into specific topics which i just
um only briefly talked about
at the url we have a github page where
most of our tools are open source and we
love photographs
and
that's something super awesome and you
want to work for essay we also are
hiring
so any questions
okay
imagine should we have the mics or if it
just repeats
okay
you mentioned
that we used to have
can you elaborate on how that
process works
yeah so the question is basically how
our github request workflow works so
by the start i said we don't use
branching which was a little bit of a
lie because we use those like very short
references for pull requests
which are just when you run the review
tool it pushes up the temporary branch
to github
opensupport request assigns it to the
person you told it to
and then it sends out email to everybody
included in that review and then
basically we have a lively discussion as
you can
see on github.com as well about like
what to change it just looks good
and we also have an internal grease
monkey script which is also open source
which gives you nice acceptance buttons
where you can just like hit accept and
it just like comments with this looks
good accepted and after that you commit
your change locally so we don't usually
use like a push button
because you should only ever commit to
origin master when you're up in the push
frame so
after you got like the okay on
the review and know that your build has
to you commute it locally
so you use the same remote
so in that sense it's not the same kind
of
well
it kind of is the same because the pull
requests per se don't have a notion of
where you send the protocols from you
can easily send requests from a branch
to another branch but yeah it's not the
it's not the usual open source for the
repo and for the best workflow but it's
all in the same info
yeah
i'm just curious about the size of your
jenkins cluster and how many jobs you
have
maybe grad knows a little bit better
about the specific numbers
uh so
we have many it's actually a general
purpose tool
but maybe a better way to answer this
would be how many actually run
during deployments
um right now uh
our the
job that runs on the tri server and
um the job that runs the first build
that runs during deployment qa bill
has about 15
unique jobs in it
and then for
we have two separate test suites which
run during employment as well and those
each have about five jobs in them
at the moment total on our production uh
check-in server we have
uh around 100 unique jobs
that run with varying frequency many of
those of our ad hoc jobs that get run
only mainly
what's the most
time-consuming part
what's the most time-consuming part of
your
deployment that
you know you're not able to get uh
from
the actual funnel yeah of building
templates and assets
this is like
takes the most time because we have a
lot of languages so we have to build
templates for the languages
the assets depending on how many changes
are there in javascript to see s
we have to compile more assets but
basically our sending code over to even
to the
so we have right now we have around
70 web servers and
24 api servers so even getting the code
on 40 unit workers so even getting code
there it's usually a matter of a minute
two it was really slow
but actually waiting for
the template compiled takes a lot longer
and then as i said before we have the
nasal am500 for the
qa part of our
ci volt which
often takes around that time so
um the usual deploy looks like you're
first waiting for the template
compilation and then there are an
additional like maybe one or two minutes
away wait for the cheerio
and then manual testing depends on your
change right so there
a lot of times you have changes where
you want to be really really sure
because you touch checkout you touch
login and stuff like that so you can
easily take two to five or longer
minutes to test on staging and then
again on production make sure you really
didn't break checkout for the time
okay
and then you use script that you're
talking about
it's not yet but we're hard we're
working really hard on that to get it
open because it was really
a quick script uh wrapped around our
specific use
and we're right now working on getting
it into a segment
you essentially when you're doing a call
request
what you're doing is you're uh merging
the pull request into the local
copy of your uh
and then pushing that right yeah
so
for
the actual
um gift side of things we try to mimic
the svm way of pushing because
it's really
the web application really lives in
trunk or master right so there's no
if you're doing branching code you
really want to have this linear master
of what
is your deployment timeline how did you
change timeline look like so
on your machine you always you always
push with database to actually put your
commits at the top of
the commit timeline
to actually mimic that this is the new
state that is gonna go out with the
default
but we never use the merge button and we
usually don't have merch commits because
it's all that very linearly based
timeline
does the
eventual
push
is
there's always a developer there's if
you change code it's your responsibility
to push it up to github it's your
responsibility to test it and it's your
responsibility to get it deployed
there's no like throwing code over to
the walls or someone else who then has
to deploy the changes to make sense of
what you wrote basically so
um the review process is just to get
insights from other people people's work
also with the code
there's something
to
improve to get more eyes on code but
it's up to you when to merge it and push
it and deploy actually since you're
doing a
just to confirm so you do not have to go
through the review process technically
no there's nothing stopping you from
just pushing and deploying other than
the graphs going up after that and
people asking you
what that change right
so what's the consequence to the graphs
going up like so other than just
ridicule from
is it just a ridicule problem is it a
peer pressure
problem
you don't assume people kind of work to
do a bad job right it's just like of
course there's a spike in the graph
everybody who was in the last push train
figures out which change
was the problem
you either revert to change or go
forward with
a fix if it's fast and then you check
your apps if the spikes go back down
can you tell me your strategies about
managing database scheme changes and
dependencies between database game
changes
yes so
commentators are not they're
continuously deployed but they're not as
frequently deployed so we do schema
changes about once a week
and schemas always have to be backwards
compatible
because we can't we're not tying skimmer
changes to deploys so
um we have what we call skip
thursday so
at that point
it can be that just the middle of life
but it can also be early or later
depending on schedule of the dba or
the developers image
and
yeah so we have a couple of rules around
how student chains can look so they have
to be famous compatible you don't do
deletes so you don't accidentally like
delete columns from data which is still
used by code
and it's very not tied together
right yeah
do you ever do rollbacks
there's no such thing as rollback
because
at that point you have no idea
what actually changed in your
application you don't know if there was
data into the database which is now not
backwards compatible so we always ever
roll forward
no it's all one gift yeah so we have
this monolithic keeps the application
and all of them
some exceptions are the search stack
because it's completely different and
the photo stack which was shot out of
that but the api the web
our external tools all wonderful
so with the prior answer about jenkins
running multiple uh jobs posts deployed
to validated and it's only going forward
so what happens when those jobs fail
so it depends which job failed right so
we have the qa and our princess tests
running when you deploy staging so when
those tests fail you figure out why they
fail you push a change and you redeploy
the staging
and basically the same goes for
production if the reduction has failed
you have a problem production so you
look at the code and figure out why it's
broken because we usually have very
small chain sets right so it should be
kind of fast intact which change
actually broke the build and then you
either revert the change
or
you
fix it and redeploy but it's all a
matter of figuring out what uh which
change broke the build and re-deploying
no so we have a qa team
which is basically an infrastructure
team to manage jenkins and
test infrastructure and test setup but
we don't actually
have someone coming in testing your
changes
to see if they work or not as a
developer your responsibility is to
change adjust your changes and make sure
that it works
so
um in that uh chain of commands let's
just show it about pushback you only
ever hit dot done
when you're uh confident that nothing's
wrong and even if you like say you're
confident and everything that's done you
do got done and something actually
breaks you can still jump the queue and
their commands to
jump in front of someone so when that
happens and people are
like the next train is deploying
basically you can either ask them to
join the training with their commands to
join the train or if it's like really
really urgent you can jump in front of
the train and say hey i have an
emergency push because this is broken
yeah the bolt is completely triggered
from the deployment system there is
nothing that you have to do like when
you hit the deploy button deployment
systems tells jenkins to run the builds
and
the results will also be posted back
entirely with a link to the actual
results
it's something we want to do but we
haven't done yet
150 developers all adding little
incremental code changes what is the
expectation about for whatever change
they put in adding
more qa tests or not you know to the
change like in other words i would
imagine if everyone keeps changing
little bits of code and they keep
writing little tests to prove it the
amount of qa tests has to keep growing
it to keep growing unbounded or is there
not an expectation that the amount of qa
tests is ever increasing the development
code change
yes no so
of course you have to test the changes
and you have to write tests for stuff
you add
but you can never catch everything in
the united states or you can never catch
everything intact you never know
so
monitoring and watching graphs is the
other side of testing so you want to
have this continuous feedback group of
actually take a look at the graphs and
see if everything's fine and not
figure out what it is so there's no
nobody checks on you
if you actually wrote a new unit test
for something if you test for something
but you have to make the conscious
decision of does that make sense to add
a huge test can i just
add an existing test
and as i said we monitor test runtimes
restricted so whenever there's
a slow test or the new slow test we try
to work with everybody to figure out how
we can make it faster and how we can
uh keep it fast
it's sort of off topic but
do any of the teams use uh any planning
strategies like scrum
that would like a time box
yeah so
we have a lot of small teams for um
writing
motivated features to the site and
there's no
global like
policy of what you have to use basically
teams decide for themselves how
uh how they work best
and so they've been if there are any
time-lapse ones where there'd be like a
lot of work done at the end of the week
or
at the end of the cycle
not done
the previous question uh so
after after the string is over
uh you just flip the switch in the code
right
to another feature yeah to kind of
finish the feature service
circle
right
but deployment is not related to that no
well
um flipping a switch is a conflict
employee basically but we never go from
zero to a hundred percent users um for
something so we have ramp ups in there
we usually go like five ten fifteen
percent and stuff like that to figure
out
for one um to run our experiments to see
if the future does what we want if it
has the effect on users we want
and
also to
simply do load testing to see if spikes
go on a database when more users use a
feature and stuff like that
and
that is basically it so when you're
basically when you're done writing code
to ramp up your future and
uh tightly watch graphs to see what's
happening
so your experiments as you call them are
being tested on your customers
it's
basically a big php config file which
gets deployed with the config port
is that what you're asking
it's it's basically the same
it has the same semantics of a regular
employee you edit the file to cut the
production content file and you push it
with the same tool but in the different
key
and then you watch graphs make sure
everything works
all the servers are always running the
same code and all the bucketing and the
uh mechanics are done in the code so
there is no
uh buttoning persona basically
so you have stuff like if feature food
is turned on to this and octopus
can you
provide some more detail into your
like how do you
aggregate information from dispatching
systems
um before you actually show it to
whatever
right so all the system of the metric
stuff is scanning for us
and we have different clusters for the
different concerns basically and all the
application level metrics are going
through nc
and get that aggregated and like
um
mean standard deviation for timings or
regulations of counters and then send
off the graphite
and then the dashboards that just chose
to deploy basically a combination of
either ganglia perhaps if you care about
system metrics so deploy dashboard for
example has
apache requests and database metrics on
there as well which are currently data
as well as
logins and checkouts which are coming
from sd graphite
do you
want to get stats from hermione and
stuff like that yeah
uh yeah we also have cdn metrics here we
have lobster also which
was boxer which is one of our also
students to get
metrics out of log files
but
basically
everything that system level is in
ganglia and everything else
thanks for listening